kate green um
if i can just ask you on covid
um what do you make of what matt hancock
has just been saying
do you think do you think we're heading
towards uh ending lockdown
on june 21st and are you happy about
that
well it's a very difficult a very finely
balanced decision
for the government and it's absolutely
right that it's taken on the basis of
all the
available data and that it's
transparently taken and that it's robust
uh obviously we're all keen to see
things get as near to normal as possible
as quickly as possible but that must be
done with public health in mind
and so i would say if we have to
maintain some protective measures
beyond the 21st of june that is what the
government should do but um
i think it is really important as a
decision taken on the basis of the data
but knowing what you do now what you
know now
um would you basically go along with the
noise that's coming from government at
the moment which is
there is no reason yet to
deviate from the road map which
essentially
heads to lifting all the restrictions
on june the 21st what i'm hearing
different experts say is that it's very
finely balanced that it's not a
clear-cut decision at this stage
so i don't think i'm in a position to
say today and i don't think the
government should be in a position to
say today
what will be the answer on june the 21st
i think it's a very
finely balanced decision um it's one
that's got to be taken with the benefit
of
all the data on one that the government
has to be absolutely open and
transparent about
and accountable for are you going to
welcome
the prime minister's call to jab
the world by the end of next year
i'm afraid i didn't hear that trevor
sorry i asked you if
uh labor is going to welcome the prime
minister's call to the g7
to have the whole world jabbed uh by
the end of ninth of night of next year
2022.
yes i think that's a really good call
because we've all known that unless
everybody in the world is safe nobody is
fully safe and of course
while i really welcome the progress that
we've made in this country with rolling
out the vaccination program the nhs our
scientists have done a wonderful
job and we obviously still have and
people who need to
receive the vaccine here and it's very
important that for example in the areas
where we're seeing
a rise in the delta infection uh that we
have surge vaccination programs put in
place and effective but
i do think that it is absolutely our
obligation um
as global as members of the global
community to make sure that we
are getting vaccines to people in the
countries that desperately need them
and making sure that those people are
safe because that's the right thing to
do morally
and it's in the interests of everybody
in the world and including in this
country
on education um you've criticized the
government over its plans
for a catch-up program and so kevin
collins uh
who you've supported this week said that
the government
would need to spend something like 15
billion pounds
um would you support kevin collins's
program for an extended school day which
is what
most of the money would have been spent
on
well we've put forward our own proposals
which also include
an activities after the end of the
formal school day and breakfast clubs
before the start of the formal school
day
and i very much welcome the suggestions
that kevin collins is making many of
them
are very similar to the proposals that
we are putting forward
we know that activities you know art
sports drama and so on
um schools have wonderful facilities to
offer it's a shame for those facilities
to shut up shop at 3 30 when children
could continue to benefit from them we
know that children's emotional and
social well-being is as
important to parents and teachers right
now as as making up lost learning
so those activities will give them a
real chance to to enjoy their childhoods
to
to rebuild that social well-being but
also of course
it will benefit children and young
people's learning
and so yes um i think kevin cohen's
proposals are very good
and i do very much welcome the proposal
to use extra time at the beginning of
the end of the school day to offer
uh those additional activities your
proposals
are priced at about 14.7 billion
pounds from the document you've issued
collins says 15 billion over the next
three years
okay they overlap but um is the shadow
chancellor
rachel reeves okay with you wanting to
spend something north of
20 billion pounds of public money over
the next three years
is that labour policy so these proposals
signed off by rachel and the shadow
treasury team with the support of the
entire shadow cabinet because we are
entirely committed
to giving priority to children and young
people's education
you may have heard keir starmer saying
it was his number one priority
in his interview with piers morgan
earlier this week
we've costed these proposals very
carefully if people want to look at our
children's recovery plan they can see
the detail of every element of that plan
and how we've costed it we also know
that the government itself and quite
rightly
has set aside a covered reserve to get
the country back on its feet
after the pandemic what we're not we're
talking about is um
how do we spend money that the
government knows it will have to spend
we're talking about priorities here
so i would say that um it's absolutely
right that we should give
top priority to children and young
people that's our responsibility to them
as adults
but it's also in our interest as a
country because the cost of not spending
14 and a half billion pounds now
in terms of lost earnings lost
productivity in the future will run into
hundreds of billions of pounds and i'm
delighted and very grateful to rachel
and my shadow treasury colleagues
uh for their very very constructive
support and help
just to be a package together clear just
to be absolutely clear this does include
an extended school day um and by the way
are the teaching unions okay with that
more hours
for teachers yes so what we're talking
about is a range of activities at the
end
at the end of the school day some
including sport art drama culture so on
there could be also the opportunity for
some formal teaching and learning
um we're not saying that any teacher
would have to do that and indeed a lot
of the
sports and music and so on might be done
by youth and community groups although
teachers who want to would be able to
and would be paid to do so
uh we have had been in very close
discussions with the the teaching unions
and they
they understand that position we've
agreed that we will
make sure with them that we're tracking
exactly how any extension of school
of activities after the school day
impacts on workloads so that there can
be very quick
um measures taken if it if it creates
unacceptable burdens on teachers
but you know teachers and the teaching
unions are as committed as anyone
to children and young people's futures
more so it's their day job it's what
they care about
and when i hear the government
rubbishing teachers rubbishing the
teaching unions
rubbishing the professionals who've
worked so hard over the last year
to support our children and young people
when i know that we have had the most
constructive and helpful discussions
with them
frankly i think it's disgraceful all
right i think
let's just talk about keep talking about
the money for for the moment
i see this morning that labor is saying
that
the um tax deal uh
navigated by rishi sunak should
provide dividends for health and
education um
now you've already given boris johnson a
pretty big tick on his um
uh jabbing the world proposition are you
going to congratulate rishi sunak
this morning on um his triumph because
usually it's
it's labor who's calling for crackdown
on tech multinationals and
uh transnationals and uh the the richest
in the world
and they've seen he seems to have done
it
labour very much supported joe biden's
call for a global tax floor of 21
so it's it's a first step but i must say
it's disappointing
uh that we have achieved only 15 coming
out of the g7 this weekend and i know
that that is because rishi sunak and the
conservative government in this country
were not enthusiastic were not prepared
to back
joe biden's call for a rate of 21
percent
so i i think it's good i think it's good
that the g7 collectively have agreed
to 15 i think it's a start i think it's
disappointing that we didn't have a more
ambitious
21 percent agreed that many of the g7
countries but sadly not rishi soon act
wanted to
but at least we've made a start and that
will bring hundreds of billions of
pounds into our exchequer